coûter plus grand chose ne me surprend
de ceux du gouvernement donc là on a une
situation assez baroque c'est à dire que
des policiers manifestent pour
revendiquer un certain nombre de choses
et celui auquel ils s'adressent sera pas
remis au milieu d'eux donc moi je pense
que le rôle d'un ministre n'est pas
déploré une situation avec avec les
manifestants il est de remédier au
problème de la sécurité qui est un sujet
qui a été négligé par le pouvoir depuis
2000 17 est devenue prépondérante pour
les français il n'y a pas une semaine
qui se déroule qui se passe sans que
nous voyons à la télévision des images
terribles de policiers pris pour cibles
que nous n'entendions des faits divers
abominable mettant aux prises des gens
des jeunes de plus en plus jeunes avec
souvent des coups mortels et encore hier
encore hier qu'est-ce qu'il faut donc la
question de la sécurité les devenu
majeur est donc là darmana sent bien que
il doit pas être absents de ce théâtre
d'opérations du coup c'est bien qu'ils
sont en bas oui mais chacun sa place
est ce que le rôle des miss et de
manifester qui est manifestants je ne
crois pas c'est d'apporter des vraies
réponses
aujourd'hui on sait que notamment en
matière pénale le compte n'y est pas on
a un souci
manifestement avec une justice qui qui
ne suit pas toujours et qui n'offre pas
toujours les réponses que nous attendons
est ce que le texte que vous examinez en
ce moment même il répond ah ça
correctement selon plus écoutée l'avenir
le dira a toujours est il que entre le
moment où le texte démarre son examen au
parlement et le moment où il sera adopté
mise en oeuvre on sera à la fin du
quinquennat
donc ça veut dire que ce problème il
aura été laissées en jachère pendant
quasiment toute la durée du quinquennat
et l'arrivée tardive de garde des sceaux
la mise en oeuvre trop tardive des
mesures de durcissement et puis des
questions qui sont évacuées parce
qu'elles viennent de l'opposition la
question des peines planchers que nous
réclamons pour les auteurs d'actes de
violence contre les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique sont rayés d'un
trait de plume par le garde des sceaux
qui dit ça ne marche pas il faut la
certitude de la peine il faut que les
auteurs de violences sache que la peine
est certaine qu'elle sera exécutée
qu'elle sera rapidement exécuté parce
que sinon eh bien nous assistons à un
délitement de l'autorité publique qui
jette un climat de 2,2 d'inquiétude dans
la population
un niveau que nous n'avions pas connu
depuis très longtemps et donc continuer
à les réclamer des peines planchers nous
nous continuerons à réclamer des peines
planchers et tous les arguments qui nous
sont opposés par exemple la question de
la constitutionnalité
je regrette le conseil constitutionnel
avait validé les peines plancher pour
les récidivistes
donc il y a un chemin et je trouve de
façon générale que ce pouvoir est sourd
aux propositions de l'opposition il dit
en même temps il n'y a pas de
proposition et en même temps nous ne
voulons pas de vos propositions
ce n'est pas de la bonne façon de faire
la politique et je le regrette
profondément parce que c'est notre pays
qui en souffrent